can I have some suggestions for answers
one egg someone give you up I love it
11 what okay 11 70s where does this 11
centimeters come from okay so you see
these dashes right and there's a pair of
them on each meeting okay those two are
both going to be 4 centimeters so you
just did 4 plus 4 plus so you would have
converted that to 3 centimeters now it
doesn't matter whether you provided this
answer in centimeters like this or in
millimeters like that doesn't matter
there's nothing in the question that
tells you it's kind of actress you're
this particular kind of users and 11
centimeters really is 110 millimeters so
in this context no reason why you can't
just do either one so ah but B now I'm
going to offer gifts you give me an
answer and then I'm gonna actually get
you to do some working with me on this
question because interesting has someone
got a perimeter for me 92 92 okay sounds
like we've got agreement okay now
something I want to point out is that
you can see here I don't know if you
actually noticed this is this is from a
book but I read this in this is no I did
not be for you you actually do know if
you think back a couple of years yeah
you know Pythagoras theorem so you can
actually work out this edge without me
telling you okay now let's just rehearse
because we haven't looked at this really
long how do we go about doing this
in a right angle triangle what
information will you need to know like
this let's just suppose I don't know
that yet okay what am I gonna have to do
yeah many okay very good sir the words
for this uh-huh maybe sadness boils down
we're saying it but the sum of the
squares son of the two squares of the
shorter sides in writing the triangle is
this is equal to the square of the what
we call again
the hypotenuse is that long one yeah so
what are the short sides 10 and 20
you've got the 10 here cuz it again the
same two lines have you got the 20 few
cuz there's single - is there so up here
and I'd love you want to write this with
me if you did not I mean you didn't need
to because I gave the 22 so I love you
to write with me 10 squared plus 20
squared equals C squared
right that's a hundred plus 400 so C
squared equals 500 but that's kind of an
aikidoka you've got a calculator that
can work out what C is for you you press
the square root button you should get
someone told me there's more places give
me two or three and you can see where I
got the number from right now why do you
think I what i actually did provided to
you why do you think I rounded it to
that level correct so I've got kind of
going with yeah I think this is the
accuracy you've gone and so therefore
nearest either seems reasonable
okay by the way I should point out
actually look at these I don't really
good it's than yours be done
do you why and don't actually because
those zeros the 1 0 the 2 0 make could
this years of not just measurement they
could have come from rounding right like
an approximation so this without this it
could have been to the nearest 10 meter
but I thought I'd be a bit awkward to
call this 20 and that 20 and saved a bit
of funky so that's why I've split to the
nearest long but that gave you the 92
okay can we just ask this last bit
greatest possible error what did you
have for this 11.5 okay again can we
dissect where does that number come from
okay yeah no milk number one there are
three measurements three times we're
taking this so I'm gonna work out my
arrow go to triplet how did we know that
the error was zero point five seven it's
for h1 I'll go down but why is your
point five why not like zero point one
zero five how did you yeah you look
carefully at what accuracy is given to
you and then you say it's half of the
limit of reading okay and even though it
says 30 if you look at you like oh it's
in millimeters but it's 30 so that zero
could have come from Randy so three lots
of have said to be no perfect this one
so again we look at the limit of reading
which is a beat up okay we have that
which gives us zero point five and you
look at how many times you use that
measurement one two three four five it's
a bit interesting than this five right
so this is a we didn't have an
equivalent word to you so that it's a
bit interesting that it's two point five
because what kind of shape how'd you
what name would you give to this shape
I'm sorry I meant the whole shape
whole prove it up how many sides this is
see yeah
I can just let me have a reco I count
one two three four sites so to question
of a specific client where right now
this is really important this is it's a
really glad we notice this there are
full of science there four sides but in
order to get the length of this one
right you use this one measurement twice
do you notice that right so if there was
an airing here well it's going to get
doubled when we take it out all the way
to the end so that's why the error comes
in five times not four even though it's
a quadrilateral okay